so diese woche haben wir als
nachrichtensatire also man erfahren wie
das ist selber in den nachrichten
vorzukommen nicht schön
stichwort erster mai dazu später mehr
kommen wir erst mal zur top nachricht
der woche
deutschland macht sich locker und wie es
hat sich ausgeloggt dauert jetzt wird
wieder in die hände gespuckt
beziehungsweise in die armbeuge ist ja
klar
alle läden machen auf gastronomie hotels
unter auflagen sportanlagen und und und
das wilde lockerungs rennen der
provinzfürsten ist gar nicht mehr zu
stoppen
vier restaurants und cafés die dürfen
bei wieder aufmachen am montag ab dem 15
mai rollt der ball wieder in der ersten
und zweiten fußball bundesliga und am
achtzehnten öffnen in bayern die
biergärten in nrw sind ab muttertag
wieder besuch im pflegeheim möglich
öffnung von hotels in der zweiten
maihälfte freibäder dürfen am
zwanzigsten mal wieder öffnen
ab dem 30 mai folgen hallenbäder oder
badeseen
also im prinzip macht alles wieder auf
außer kitas und putz hallenbäder wir das
ganze virus nur geträumt oder was leider
nein
wir erleben gerade live die entmachtung
der angela merkel
der druck der ministerpräsidenten der
lockeren jungs war schlicht zu gross war
zu groß angeblich hat die kanzlerin am
mittwoch in der telefon schalte den
legendären satz gesagt ich bin kurz
davor aufzugeben
ein satz den jede mutter kennt ab sofort
müssen wir uns zum beispiel wieder mit
menschen aus einem anderen haushalt
treffen
bitte wir dürfen ab gott sei dank ich
kenne überhaupt keinen anderen haushalt
es wird wirklich immer komplizierter wir
gehen rein also in die entsprechenden
offen hals beschränkungen und kontakt
beschränkungen das system 2.1 oder zwei
plus eins wird ersetzt durch das fünf
personen prinzip alles klar
5 ist das neue 2+1 am notiert im prinzip
läuft hier ab jetzt so eine art wette
können wir die bürger auch einer langen
leine vernünftig sein
der einsatz ist vielleicht was hoch
zumal es auch immer noch keine tracing
app gibt aber auch vernunft hoffen ist
wohl besser als dauerhaft grundrechte
einschränken
gleichzeitig liegt die verantwortung
damit natürlich nicht mehr bei frau
merkel
das haben jetzt die länder die im
notfall lokale lockdown verhängen
sollten aber klar für den moment ist man
einfach nur dankbar
wir dürfen wieder zum griechen alexis
bei aus bremerhaven sieht das alles
etwas experimenteller der griechische
gastronom hat eine maske mit
reißverschluss entworfen so
an jeder problemlos gleichzeitig gyros
pommes und salat essen hier der beweis
geil ich stelle mir gerade vor wie
christian drosten zu hause diese szene
sieht hh
hey wer braucht noch virologen wir haben
friseure ja unsere friseure haben wieder
geöffnet endlich die folge unter anderem
dutzende extrem sinnfreie live schalten
hier wird farbe aufgetragen
kreuzworträtsel können endlich wieder
gelöst werden wie froh bist du jetzt
dass du endlich beim friseur setzt ja
meine haare sind ziemlich lang wie
würden sie vorgehen schneiden
ich bin nicht vom fach aber friseure
also wieder an bord und am sechzehnter
startet die bundesliga mit ihren
berühmten geisterspielen ja alles andere
wäre auch eine tragödie
also jetzt nicht für die fans aber für
die vereine die sonst auf 280 millionen
fernseh kohle verzichten müssen
stelle sich das mal vor problem manche
fußballprofis sind in sachen hygiene
regeln ja ähnlich schwer zu steuern wie
kita kinder genauso doof nur viel
reicher wie das berühmte video des
hertha spielers kalou beweis indem er
lachend ohne ende hände schüttelt und
stumpf ins corona tests im rheinland
inzwischen suspendiert und sicher nur
ein einzelfall
im sogenannten hygiene konzept der liga
stehen übrigens lauter lustige sätze wie
zum beispiel der hier
die spieler sollen wäsche und schuhe
selber waschen oder eigenständig in die
waschmaschine legen natürlich viele von
denen haben noch nie eine waschmaschine
gesehen so sieht's doch aus ja und dann
ist da natürlich noch das problem mit
der fehlenden atmosphäre im leeren
stadion
hier kommt die lösung damit sich fußball
vor leeren rängen einigermaßen normal
anfühlt in gladbach können fans
pappfiguren mit ihrem foto auf der
tribüne platzieren lassen
genial ich prophezeie das wird sich
durchsetzen
auch für andere kroner probleme statt
oma und opa im altenheim zu besuchen
schickt man einfach seine pop version
solange ihre kinder nicht in die kita
dürfen bringen sie morgens ihre pub
gehen da hin
ich gehe jetzt sogar wieder regelmäßig
ins fitnessstudio also nicht ich aber
die geste zählt und jetzt kommt auch die
kirchen haben endlich wieder auf höchste
zeit höchste zeit ich weiß gar nicht
mehr wann ich zuletzt in der kirche war
meine das war während meiner
konfirmation ist ja auch egal
die kirchgänger sind jedenfalls total
erleichtert selbst wenn im haus gottes
jetzt corona regeln gelten auch beim
betreten der kirche sollen sich die
besucher nicht zu nahe kommen
mindestabstand zwei meter reduzierter
gesang ja es kann wird man soll
reduziert oder verhalten singen ich
zitiere aus der hygiene empfehlungen der
katholischen bischofskonferenz auf
lauten gemeindegesang sollte verzichtet
werden weil singen ein risiko darstellt
es richtig wegen der erosion wolken die
man da ausstößt deswegen haben sie ja
auch beim karneval so viele infiziert
lautes singen ist brandgefährlich
das müssen auch die ganz doofen mal
begreifen die denon ihr ballermann
essverhalten gesungen stimmung ohne
infektionsrisiko mit all deinen
lieblings sitz kaufen
morgens mittags abends ich will hoffen
der mega hit von mickie krause ich will
leise friseusen 10 leise friseuse kemal
bier holen
du wirst schon wieder lauter party
nonstop mit da schweigt ein pferd auf
dem flur finger in ecuador was geht ab
wir flüstern die ganze macht und
natürlich heißt die mutter von rio
reiser mama leiser mama leiser
ballermann party hits fand mitsummen
oder wendler ist nicht dabei
[Musik]
unbedingt kaufen so meine ganz andere
frage wie schlagen sich eigentlich
unsere parteien in der krise
da gibt es im moment tatsächlich nur
einen großen gewinner nämlich die union
cdu und csu haben wirklich unfassbar
zugelegt in den letzten wochen ja es ist
halt die stunde der exekutive wobei die
spd davon als koalitionspartner
bizarrerweise 0 profitiert warum auch
immer
größter verlierer der korona krise sind
aber ganz eindeutig die grünen ja es ist
so in manchen umfragen von 23 auf 16
prozent gefallen das tut sie es gab also
durchaus anlass für kontroverse debatten
auf dem kleinen grünen parteitag letztes
wochenende aber der lief erstaunlich
harmonisch und es war der erste komplett
digitale parteitag deutschlands
digitaler parteitag ist gab es noch nie
also im grunde eine gigantische
video-konferenz aber beschlussfähig das
könnte die zukunft sein oder
du müsstest deine kamera anstellen
lothar perfekt und dann deinen ton und
dann kannst du anfangen durch drei
minuten
hallo hallo hier bin hatte ich fange an
ich sehe mich aber nicht
sei doch froh lothar matthias maucksch
gehört zur task force digital green die
den parteitag organisiert hat herr
matschke auf spd niveau gesunken grüner
kanzlerkandidat nur noch ein feuchter
traum
warum wurde da trotzdem kaum gestritten
letztes wochenende also von mir erst mal
ein ganz warmes danke an die grünen
freundinnen und freunde 105 delegierte
haben mitgemacht 30.000 im livestream
zugeguckt das sind schon fast youporn
dimension also inhaltlich jetzt nicht
aber wir sind sehr happy war übrigens
nicht bin ich die ganze konferenz
technik genauso viel gekostet mine halle
zu mieten
es hat man auch absolut gemerkt bitte
schalten jetzt deine kamera ein hörte
mich so gut es gibt ein kurzes problem
ich höre gar nichts mehr
und diesen antrag bringt ein robert
habeck funktioniert übertreiben wir
hören das aber wir sehen dich nicht
thomas mann hört ich leider nicht könnt
ihr mich hören
martin gehören die ich noch nicht kenne
hört ihr mich jetzt wie sehen dich nicht
mal gut
es ist spät aber die stummschaltung ist
aufgehoben und das mögen ja mein gott
kinderkrankheiten weltweit erster
digitaler parteitag der welt vor allem
haben die anna lena und erobert sich am
ende durchgesetzt mit ihrem leitantrag
darum geht es doch dass wir
zusammenbleiben ja ja es wurde nicht nur
über vermögenssteuer gestritten
ist demnächst das thema wer bezahlt für
corona dazu von den grünen nur die alte
phrase starke schultern können mehr
tragen ja wie viel mehr ab welcher
schulterbreite die grünen sind in den
letzten jahren so erfolgreich
vorgedrungen ganz tief ins rektum der
bürgerlichen milieus das versauen wir
uns doch jetzt nicht mit
steuererhöhungen
ich las mit diesem parteitag nicht
kaputtreden der robert hat so tolle
sachen gesagt also jetzt nicht über
steuern aber dafür so allgemein gerade
jetzt wo alles nur gegenwart und krise
zu sein scheint öffnet sich auch eine
tür zur zukunft verhindern wir einen
reaktionären rückfall kämpfen wir
stattdessen für die renaissance des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts vielen
dank
bravo klartext wir müssen wieder ins 21
jahrhundert haben bin ich seit 20 jahren
das einundzwanzigste jahrhundert das ist
ja wir haben gerade mal eine kleine
umfrage delle klima und umwelt sind halt
plötzlich aus der mode
weil die deutschen sich immer nur auf
ein thema gleichzeitig konzentrieren
können diese fruchtfliegen naja
stichwort umwelt beim parteitag forderte
einen konsumgutschein dann könnte ich
aber komplett bei mediamarkt verballern
und eben nicht im kleinen
eigentümergeführten dritte-welt-laden
acht der ist doch ich schon pleite der
scheiß teeladen ich kann die grünen
klischees nicht mehr hören lieber herr
matschie diese woche hat ein grüner
ministerpräsident kaufprämien für
verbrenner gefordert ich möchte das noch
mal sagen weil es so lustig klingt ein
grüner ministerpräsident fordert
kaufprämien für verbrenner sorry aber
dazu ist jetzt echt alles gesagt der
winfried regiert eben baden württemberg
da geht's regeln
ich nehme daimler es klassikern fiat
fahrer ganz genau kann er nicht unter
digitaler parteitag war ein voller
erfolg das bilder entstanden die werden
für immer bleiben
[Applaus]
matthias matschke was denn über meinen
arsch geigensolo war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]